so one of the things that i think is
misunderstood about leadership is that
it's not just from the top leaders have
to set set the environment for sure and
leaders have to uh uh
lead by example for sure
but you know this is our organization
this is your organization like you don't
get to nobody gets to sit on the
sidelines and be like all right what
have you done for me lately right um you
know i don't even mind negativity you
know you know people like oh my goodness
that person's such a negative nelly but
because sometimes negative people who
are in the fight and they're still
willing to they show up every day
they're great you know it's it's when
people are negative and they just stand
on the sides and throw stones and there
and i don't mean like bring me solutions
that's not what i mean i mean just like
you're in it you're in the scrum and and
you're willing to be a part of it so
like you have to come to work here every
day there's a there's a great story when
gordon bethune took over continental
airlines which was what
which existed prior to united
um they merged um it was a terrible
airline it was the worst rated airline
in the country for every every metric
and one of the things that was bad was
the planes were always dirty
and the the customers would always
complain and they would always get
yelled at by management clean the planes
for the customer the customers are
complaining and when gordon bethune
showed up he said forget about the
customer they're on the plane they're
off the plane in three hours you have to
do four you're gonna have to do four
more flights before your shift is done
why don't you clean the plane for
yourselves like this is your office like
once you keep it nice for yourself
in fact there's a there's a funny
statistic between ups trucks and u.s
postal service trucks which is u.s post
u.s um postal service trucks um uh i
think they only last about two years
before they have to be replaced
and ups trucks last something like five
years before they have to get replaced
ups they clean their trucks every single
day and u.s postal service trucks they
clean their trucks once a week
because when you give somebody something
really nice to work in they look after
it
and so like it becomes incumbent upon
all of us to say this is when we're
talking about leadership which is if you
see someone struggling go to them if you
see someone who's unhappy maybe you know
go to them if somebody's stuck in a
false narrative maybe help them change
their narrative give them a safe space
to feel heard sometimes people just need
to empty their bucket some people
sometimes just need to vent and get it
all out and then they're actually fine
and sometimes what we do by mistake is
trying to interrupt them correct the
facts fix the problem
and so we can be that like you can be
that for the people you work with that's
a huge part of it like taking
responsibility for the organization in
which you work yes leadership does bear
some responsibility of course but i
think everybody in the organization is
included in that as well we want people
not to just fit the culture but to be
additive and contribute to the culture